[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos al primer plano programa de
radio france internacional y de france
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en el
control de los contenidos en redes a
partir de la polémica compra de twitter
lo hacemos en este estudio con tres
invitadas ángela cubillos es abogada
experta en derecho digital bienvenida
ángel a él la tomas y mi periodista
consultor en comunicación bienvenida del
dap muchas gracias y adriana seminario
es experta en marketing digital
bienvenida adriana muchas gracias el
control de contenidos en redes a partir
de la polémica compra de twitter por
parte de lo más hoy nuestro asunto en
primera plana
[Música]
el hombre más rico del mundo presidente
de tesla y de varias compañías más que
abarcan un gran una gran parte del plano
económico mundial y lo más se ha hecho
con twitter con la intención manifiesta
por su parte de mejorar la red social
así como hacerla más independiente en lo
que a libertad de expresión se refiere
aunque haya menos filtros ahora muchos
analistas temen que la red se convierta
en la ley de la selva' con los cambios
que planea el nuevo propietario que
pretende acabar con los bots y el spam
abrir el código de la red para que todo
el mundo tenga acceso a su algoritmo e
instalar las cuentas de pago está compra
ha reabierto el debate sobre el control
de los que los gigantes de internet
ejercen sobre el contenido que publican
sus usuarios vamos a repasar algunas
portadas que nos trae este asunto en
'new york post' ahí tienen al nuevo jefe
de twitter subido al logotipo del pájaro
azul reconocible de la red social con un
más acordonando su pico la revista
'time' usando otra poderosa imagen en su
portada con un must que encierra pájaros
azules en una jaula aquí en francia esa
compra también tiene repercusión en
portadas como ésta de la aparición que
subraya la ámbito sin límites del
magnate o como ésta de la cual que se
preguntase a partir de ahora de ahora
hay que tener miedo de twitter vamos a
ir del caso concreto de twitter a luego
hablar de la cuestión de fondo que puede
afectar a cualquier red social pero les
pregunto de primeras si hay motivos para
la inquietud por esta compra desde el
punto de vista jurídico yo consideraría
que no porque existe un marco jurídico
que reglamenta la libertad de expresión
entonces digamos que existen garantías
de orden constitucional de orden a nivel
europeo existen directivas también
digamos que incluso si la concepción de
libertad de los mismos puede ser una
concepción absolutista esta concepción
es subjetiva y debe atender a las normas
es decir el olmos puede comprar todo
menos la ley para mí vale vamos a hacer
una ronda rápida y luego hablemos sobre
esos conceptos él da motivos para
inquietud o no no yo creo que no que
justamente hoy twitter
necesitaba también un cambio había mucho
debate en torno a qué cosas se censuran
y cómo se hacen tener conocimientos
quizás del algoritmo y también para
cuidar los datos de los usuarios son las
cosas que plantea más que pueden traer
un debate muy interesante adriana
antes de responder eso me gustaría
señalar que es en las portadas que
acaban de enseñar es bastante irónico
que se muestre que el o más lo que él
dice que quiere liberar las redes
sociales que demasiada censura pero las
imágenes muestran un poco lo contrario
que es esta preocupación como
dice angela y elda yo creo que sí habría
cierta cierta preocupación en el sentido
que
finalmente son los usuarios los que
hacen la plataforma no los dueños no los
programadores no ninguna de estas
personas del equipo interno son los
usuarios mismos y twitter me parece que
es una de las plataformas que tiene más
libertad de expresión pero no seamos
ingenuos las redes sociales pueden ser
bastante
difíciles pueden ser ambiente bastante
agresivos sí que se necesita una cierta
reglamentación
y finalmente si esto se cambia yo creo
que yo creo que lo más podría empujar un
poco más hacia esos territorios
siendo el dueño realmente también
depende de cada gobierno de cada país
como en europea como comentaba hella es
muy estricto pero yo creo que podría
haber ciertos motivos de inquietud a
largo plazo que lo más que claro les veo
muy optimista espero que lo más se haga
defensor de la democracia y de la
libertad de expresión no es por sí ya
inquietante que el hombre más rico del
mundo
aparezca como el mesías de la libertad
de expresión pues él quiere digamos
abrirlo porque abrir la posibilidad de
la libertad de expresión en eeuu porque
digamos y es la diferencia que tenemos
con otros territorios otras
jurisdicciones es que el primer la
primera enmienda a la constitución de
eeuu es muchísimo más amplia sobre lo
que se entiende como libertad de
expresión en eeuu es posible hablar del
nazismo y digamos que acá hay la
incitación al odio a temas de por
ejemplo discriminación
eso sí se encuentra digamos regulado el
más restringido acá entonces yo pensaría
que en realidad ese concepto de libertad
de expresión que él tiene es un concepto
absolutista él piensa que en la libertad
de expresión lo permite todo y olvida
que la libertad de expresión tiene unos
límites que como bien tú lo decías son
en la moderación
actualmente de hecho
la unión europea en muy lejos el 23 de
abril expidió una reglamentación a nivel
europeo la digital service act que
obliga a todas las plataformas digitales
a realizar la moderación y respetar y
digamos que eso tiene unas consecuencias
jurídicas porque hay sanciones de manera
que si él quiere crear o atender azul
concepto subjetivo de libertad de
expresión va a tener que respetar porque
de lo contrario en el territorio europeo
pues va a tener unas sanciones de 6 por
ciento sobre la cifra de negocios global
que él hace e incluso también se le
puede cerrar la plataforma a nivel
europeo entonces digamos que la
reglamentación como es una twitter es
una plataforma que funciona a nivel
global tiene
las únicas condiciones generales de
utilización y por lo tanto de respetar
no va a realizar unas condiciones
generales de utilización es para cada
país particular sino que tiene que
respetar el conjunto de reglamentaciones
internacionalmente para que todos los
usuarios puedan participar en cualquier
caso la libertad de expresión no no la
tiene que conceder un magnate sino que
debe estar recoge de las constituciones
y los derechos fundamentales
porque sólo para citar en washington
paul de hecho él dijo
el manejo de una red social es correcto
si el 10% de los extremistas de derecha
e izquierda no están contentos es su
concepción según el ahora que a quien
estamos llamando es permitas que podemos
decir estas cuentas extremista esta
cuenta es extrema y empezar los líos en
los
terrenos pantanosos en la que de por sí
no debemos esperar a ver qué pasa pero
creo que también hay un costo de más que
más allá de defender la libertad de
expresión y lo que explicaba ella de
quizás un concepto diferente a lo que
puede ser en otros lugares por ser de
eeuu pero tiene también un rol bastante
pedagógico y está escuchando bastante a
los usuarios cómo poner funciones como
se dice de editar algunos tuits o por
ejemplo ayer el mismo es muy activo en
las redes sociales y le explicaba a
explicar a los usuarios cómo evitar el
algoritmo que es justamente que te
muestre tus preferencias entonces cómo
hacer esa es tu propia curaduría de
contenidos y poner del lado de los
usuarios el poder de la plataforma y de
informarnos entonces digo si hay algunos
cambios que pueden ser muy interesantes
si protegemos con nuestros datos y si va
hacia eso y si abren el algoritmo
público para poder hacer algunas
intervenciones de hecho en esa línea en
esa línea justo el mencionó una de las
cosas que dice que va a ser muy dice que
va a ser muchas cosas obviamente pero
las primeras es que va a transformar el
también coronel ohiko nuevamente piedra
explicó eso exactamente como vos podés
entrar a tu cuenta y ponerlo duro
cronológico y eso te va a permitir
seguir más a los usuarios o creas 41 mil
millones de dólares ha pagado más por
twitter pero más dice que no lo hace por
dinero que lo hace por la libertad de
expresión por salvar la democracia no sé
hasta qué punto es creíble esto es decir
cuáles son las razones del trasfondo de
esta compra en la historia creo que
alguien que se presenta como yo voy a
salvar la democracia tiene un rol hoy de
mis días de yo soy esa es eso
históricamente da un poco de
desconfianza en mi opinión sin embargo
y esto no solamente lo vemos con hilos
más lo vemos con meta
de todas maneras facebook instagram
whatsapp entonces es que la web 2 es
algo que realmente debería comenzar a
deberíamos criticar reconsiderar la
gente habla de la web 3 de el metaverso
de todo lo que se viene en ese sentido
entonces yo sí y el metaverso es
descentralizado esto también es el
primer punto es que las grandes
corporaciones
adelantándonos un poco van a querer
poner la mano en este tipo de web 3 yo
creo que hay una discusión bien bien
oscura un poco
la diferencia es que bueno ser el dueño
de una plataforma es diferente a lo que
pasó con facebook instagram y whatsapp
que pertenecen las tres a la misma
empresa quizás eso es desaparecer de una
de esas redes y desaparecer del entorno
digital y también twitter bueno es una
de las plataformas disponibles creo que
bueno algunos se pueden intentar más o
no con el personaje de él o más con su
persona con lo que dice pero en
principio creo que bueno no debemos
cuestionarnos tanto de eso sino poner de
vuelta que podemos hacer nosotros con
esa red
en ese sentido digamos que yo tampoco
estaría inquieta porque existe en eeuu
como acá una autoridad la federal trade
commission y la security exchange
comission y ellos actualmente de hecho
la compra no está formalizada totalmente
porque actualmente ellos están haciendo
el control de concentración del mercado
elon musk público que la iba a adquirir
y él normalmente tenía que haber
cumplido con un procedimiento de
declaración porque él adquiría más del 5
por ciento de la compañía adquirió el
100 por ciento
este tipo de adquisiciones pasan por un
control de la autoridad de la
competencia en eeuu que es la federal
trade commission que actualmente digamos
está estudiando la compra entonces
digamos que ese estudio se va a hacer
para poder garantizar que no existe una
concentración de pues digamos ya lo
existe porque hay muchos gigantes de
internet que tiene el control facebook
adquirió instagram adquirió whatsapp
entonces digamos que esas plataformas de
hecho también tienen que ser objeto de
una desconcentración porque son mercados
pertinentes diferentes y actualmente de
hecho desde el año pasado entró en vigor
la digital market
act que también busca justamente
proteger el mercado y poder permitir que
otras plataformas digitales tengan
espacio en la web y sean también
utilizadas por los usuarios
el hombre se reunió esta semana con
thierry bretón comisario europeo del
mercado interior y servicios y aseguró
que twitter planea cumplir con la ley de
servicios digitales con la que europa
quiere frenar la difusión de contenidos
ilegales y desinformación en redes
sociales no sé si esto puede
tranquilizar en parte no si se lo
comentaba ella es totalmente así a mí lo
que me parece que estamos dejando un
poco de lado es el uso que se hace de la
red de hecho más allá de la moderación y
de las penalidades que puede haber desde
el lado legal todos
los trucos para hablar de ciertos temas
que existen en la web todos los usuarios
de twitter saben que hay palabras que
están penalizadas o que están
paralizadas y que entonces lo que se
tiende a hacer es bueno más allá existe
el algo speech también poner la primera
letra no y de una palabra que por la
cual te pueden censurar el tweet y el
resto las sacas por contexto no sólo nos
en la primera letra y word entonces digo
también es eso digo la ley que hasta
donde alcanza verdaderamente a la
regulación del contenido porque los
usuarios finalmente son los que hacen la
plataforma qué conversaciones quieren
tener para que quiera usar esa red
entonces está bien que la ley exista y
por supuesto que regule pero más allá de
las regulaciones para mí es volver a
pensar que queremos y que pretendemos de
las redes sociales
me preocupa mucho es el concepto
jurídico de la desinformación porque
digamos que yo entiendo totalmente
nosotros las otras prohibiciones
contenidos ilícitos pero el concepto de
la desinformación puede prestarse para
que digamos que haya un control si el
algoritmo no es neutro y no hay
neutralidad en la plataforma que puedan
haber arbitrariedades y por supuesto en
el contexto actual en el que estamos
actualmente digamos que la no violencia
es muy importante porque si podemos
generar contenidos que están
desinformando en el contexto mundial
actual pues podemos generar catástrofes
vamos a dejar y en unos instantes
retomamos desde estos contenidos de la
biológica desinformación muy interesante
como ven
vamos a cenar para press bauzà volvemos
a seguir en primera plana
ah
tras 25 años de guerra civil angola no
ha pasado la página a pesar del silencio
de las armas los estigmas aún permanecen
lo reconstruir esta casa estamos
mostrando a nuestro odio creo que eso es
lo que hay que superar creo que hay
otras formas quienes lucharon por el
país denuncian abandono mientras la
corrupción amplifica las desigualdades a
los veteranos nos tratan como si
fuéramos basura nos pisotean
pero una nueva generación parece haber
retomado ideas de cambio y paz
para mí vivir en paz sería vivir en una
sociedad de justicia con sus pies
boleto de vuelta a angola en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
y
[Música]
france24 la economía día a día
liberté égalité actuality esta semana a
partir aquí en primera plana a partir de
la compra de lo más de twitter nos
planteamos el control que ejercen las
plataformas sobre el contenido publicado
por los usuarios y esta polémica compra
y todos los ángulos que encierre lo
hacemos con ángela cubillos abogada
experta en derecho digital nos acompaña
también en la toma sin y periodista y
adriana seminario experta en marketing
digital con las búsquedas en línea
dominadas por google y la empresa matriz
de facebook me está adquiriendo la las
plataformas de redes sociales más
grandes del mundo para acumular
3600 millones de usuarios activos
mensuales es decir casi la mitad del
planeta el discurso en línea se ha
centralizado bajo un puñado de
sombrillas corporativas esta es la gran
cuestión de fondo si yo pensaría que sí
y de hecho llevamos bastante tiempo
desde el ámbito jurídico intentando
encontrar cómo hacer para desmantelar
los gigantes de internet dividir
corporaciones urbanas y de forma directa
es decir
habría que partir facebook en varias
partes facebook no no lo sabré si
facebook digamos es propietario de
varios servicios diferentes que dirigen
mercados pertinentes diferentes está el
servicio de comunicación de whatsapp el
servicio de instagram y el servicio de
facebook lo mismo sucede con google
google tiene muchos mercados diferentes
y nos hemos dado cuenta que ha existido
abuso de posición dominante google de
hecho ya ha sido sancionado en la unión
europea por eso porque existen varios
mercados pertinentes y con su motor de
búsqueda por ejemplo saco a un a un a un
programa de google cartográfica que
buscaba
mostrar toda la parte de localización
territorial entonces cómo creó su propia
aplicación de google maps edición es
decir eliminó de su plataforma a google
cartografía y así sucede también por
ejemplo con los comparadores de compras
él había favor hizo favor izado su
aplicación gracias al motor de búsqueda
entonces digamos que si hay un abuso de
posición dominante y en este momento el
digital market busca justamente
sancionar eso
para buscarla
la transparencia cambió su nombre a
alphabet de hecho ya no se llama google
alfabeto y era justamente para mostrar
frente a la unión europea que había una
fake separación de mercados pero en
realidad yo sí pensaría que es
importante exigirles desmantelar y
dividir por cada mercado pertinente de
michel a adriana por el bien común
habría que fragmentar a grandes
compañías tecnológicas como facebook o
google estoy totalmente de acuerdo con
con ángela arias el camino que ese es el
camino es necesario descentralizar
porque finalmente todos estos productos
digitales
esto lo quiero poner una manera un poco
más directiva por las personas que nos
escuchando viendo en este momento
es es un usuario tú una persona contra
un equipo de personas altamente
calificadas en tecnología de software
tienen hasta equipo de psicólogos para
saber exactamente cuáles son los
contenidos cuáles son las acciones qué
cosas te pueden mostrar para retener su
atención más de dos segundos que es el
promedio en las redes sociales
incitar compra pero también sin tener
ideologías incitar muchas otras cosas
imaginemos todo esto en públicos
vamos a menos maduros más influenciables
más influenciables porque a lo mejor una
persona ya con cierta edad puede pero
todo esto
para un adolescente es brutal o no en la
electrónica no yo creo que no sé si es
un usuario contra la plataforma o si es
el camino descentralizar si encontrar
como como hemos encontrado con los
medios tradicionales con la social media
ciertas formas y ciertos mecanismos para
moderar para regular y vamos seguir ese
camino y también creer también en los
consumidores y en los usuarios que
tienen la capacidad de discernir de
ciertas cosas y por supuesto que hay
tendencias pero lo que nos sirve a
nosotros y que para mí me da mucha
esperanza es si nosotros conocemos el
algoritmo y cómo funciona que es una de
las promesas vamos a ver qué pasa a
diferencia de lo que lo que ocurre con
facebook o en otras plataformas que no
sabemos cómo funciona el algoritmo
conocer el funcionamiento del algoritmo
va
muy útil para que otras voces que saben
y que podemos empezar a manejar cierta
información o voces puedan llegar más
que hoy nos llegan porque si solamente
cómo funciona hoy te muestra lo que vos
pensás es muy difícil una solución
también evocada por varios analistas en
eeuu es construir una infraestructura
pública digital para garantizar que
todos los estadounidenses por ejemplo
tengan acceso y protección en su
libertad como ya existió en el pasado
con otros medios de comunicación con
otras tecnologías con los correos con el
correo como la institución pública con
el telégrafo con la radio es decir esa
especie de infraestructura pública que
sería no sé una solución o no aún no lo
ven no sé a lo mejor desde desde lo
legal lo podemos ver más claramente pues
yo digo yo yo sí considero que ya están
las plataformas ya están lo que sí
pienso es que hay lo que tú mencionabas
ese momento de los algoritmos la
neutralidad es fundamental
y lo he pensado y propondría por ejemplo
que se realice el mismo control como se
realiza con los medicamentos de las
farmacéuticas un control previo del
algoritmo para garantizar la neutralidad
de manera que los utilizadores no sean
influenciados de un hacia un sentido o
hacia un otro sino que como tú dices se
les respete su capacidad de dirimir y de
determinar qué contenido es falso qué
contenido es cierto qué contenido les
gusta o que no pero no que digamos
simpre piense que se empieza a crear un
perfil como tú dices de la persona
porque la persona pues digamos que
estaría condicionada y limitada a una
información eso puesto que una persona
entienda el algoritmo que realmente como
no está regulado los algoritmos pueden
ir es bastante puede un poco de miedo
como te pueden parecer incluso más que
ti mismo entonces en ese caso yo sí creo
que es importante tener una educación
una educación de usuario digital que es
algo que no sé si se habla mucho hoy en
día pero con estas cosas que están
sucediendo y lo más con la
centralización de meta
saber cómo
regular tu huella digital y no dejar que
el algoritmo realmente tenga toda esta
entrada hacia tu perfil personal el de
lo que hablábamos de crear otra red
crear otra vez es bastante simple yo lo
que es muy difícil es crear esa
comunidad que ya existe entonces se
pueden crear muchísimas redes de hecho
ha pasado y pasa todo el tiempo se van
creando plataformas nuevas pero lo que
no se puede trasladar en la comunidad
que ya es parte de una red entonces es
muy importante lo que ya decía
carlos convertido entre nosotras el
propósito y la conversación que cada
plataforma genera y quizás esa educación
digital que necesitamos por ejemplo nos
en el caso de linkedin la conversación
es mucho más si queremos llamarla una
manera sana y menos violenta o menos
agresiva porque tiene otro propósito la
conversación entonces digo o redit que
tiene moderadores voluntarios
moderadores de ciertos temas entonces
digo bueno cuál es nuestro rol también
como como activista como ciudadanos nos
tenemos que involucrar mucho más que
esperamos de las plataformas
interesantes en la historia siempre se
han dado casos de magnates o de holdings
empresariales controlan empresas de
comunicaciones desde luego no es nuevo
pero había detrás digamos un
accionariado no aquí ya hablamos de un
grupo reducido de personas según forbes
ocho de las diez personas más ricas de
eeuu tienen participación significativa
en los medios en línea son plataformas
supuestamente públicas pero realmente
podemos hablar de plutócratas es decir
además ahora vemos a una persona que
concentra ya son las familias que
concentraban medios de comunicación ya
vemos personas individuales que compran
una red social sí es inquietante también
ver que el olmo se está pensando también
sacará a twitter de la bolsa y estaba
mirando a la acción de twitter está
bajando digamos porque pues eso genera
un cierto pánico en los consumidores o
en los utilizadores y esto de cuando hay
un solo accionista que está deteniendo
el la totalidad el 100% de la tela de la
compañía digamos que a nivel de
governance de gobierno de la compañía
las políticas de gobierno pues como de
tiene el 100% pues es quien decide no
existe digamos ese el consejo de
administración o directivo d
de la compañía que es tan importante
digamos para tomar unas decisiones
de ideología o qué visión tienen estos
oligarcas digitales que creen creen que
si simplemente logran romper las cadenas
de regulación van a hacer florecer un
mercado de ideas algo más creativo
que tienen como visión en la cabeza de
donde llevar la red social por ejemplo
no sería
como de todos y qué piensan ellos más
allá de lo que dicen públicamente pero
hay distintos perfiles volviendo a lo
demás
hablamos hoy también de lo que venía
pasando en twitter y de la censura por
el caso por ejemplo que se ame se
discute mucho de lo que pasó con donald
trump dijo que ese fue un episodio clave
en el cual se empezó a discutir más el
tema de la censura derecho y derecho de
los más ha dicho estos días que fue un
gran error y que
creemos quizás que si no digo si una
plataforma puede censurar a un
presidente elegido democráticamente más
allá si compartimos o no sus opiniones
nosotros eso es como que donde ponemos y
dónde dónde regulamos entonces hablar
por todos los magnates es difícil lo que
sí tenemos que esperar que está
justamente lo que decimos tratar de
seguir discutiendo estos temas porque en
el caso de metaverso como explicaba ella
bueno va hacia otro lado quizás el
objetivo de azúcar ver no
es aún más descentralizado el metaverso
diferente en plataforma son diferentes
reglas por ponerlo de alguna manera y lo
que se busca la web 3 que es un poco
como se llama esta nueva propuesta es
que pueda ser más descentralizado sin
embargo bueno ya vemos que incluso se
puede comprar propiedades inmobiliarias
en la web 3 en los metaversos que hasta
rodea los 11 millones de dólares
entonces realmente es que es tan nuevo
la gente habla del cripto la gente habla
de los celtics entonces hay mucha
emoción siento como para salir de estas
de estas cadenas de estas jaulas
sociales en las cuales nos hemos
encontrado reguladas finalmente porque
los vemos en los medios por estas
personas que dicen yo quiero ser el
libertario yo quiero dar la libertad a
los usuarios al público así que siento
una una aprensión por la gente para
saltar al metaverso y a una plataforma
que sean una opción realmente donde los
usuarios puedan tener aún cierta
sensación de estar en control que es lo
que el día de hoy no ocurre nosotros
tenemos que también pensar que en
twitter hemos tenido muy buenas
experiencias y yo no creo que eso vaya a
cambiar de movilización de muchas
movilizaciones
américa latina como el movimiento y una
menos como en eeuu la web es marx bueno
muchísimos movimientos sociales la
primavera se iniciaron en twitter y yo
creo que eso hoy vas a cambiar más allá
de quién sea su dueño por sí mismo no se
puede limitar la hora de valorar las
redes sociales estaremos de acuerdo que
cosas buenas y malas están en todas las
redes sociales tan buenos están las
movilizaciones como están las face news
hay de todo si es simplemente un
elemento no podemos lo mejor enfocarlo
desde una forma buena o mala no es un
activista y que trabaja mucho de este
tema estuvo en francia esta semana decía
bueno pero también hay otros discursos
que encuentran su lugar en las redes no
hay discursos que son muy peligrosos
pero que también van encontrando otras
redes sociales donde se habla de eso
generan cuando dicen bueno que se va a
discutir en otros lados entonces
tenemos que esperar angela una frase
final que me quedan muy pocos segundos
yo diría que cuanto más elevada a la
posición de un hombre tanto mayor su
responsabilidad frente a la sociedad y
eso es una frase que debería tener muy
en cuenta yo no me gusta mucho adriana
para incluir si yo creo que de todas
maneras hay que los usuarios tienen que
tener los ojos muy abiertos y no
deberíamos dejar de ser críticos con lo
que está sucediendo sobre todo con estas
figuras con tanto poder a nivel mundial
espíritu crítico es lo fundamental para
este asunto como para otros tantos
muchísimas gracias es un placer tenerlas
hoy en este estudio realmente yo por lo
menos he aprendido muchísimo ya todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana quien en
primera plana gracias
[Música]